they say people who get involved in this
kind of stuff in the military and all
five percent of them are so or
Psychopaths they love war it isn't just
the money they they love power they love
money and a few of them are sort of bad
news Psychopaths like that they enjoy
hurting other I know that they like
seeing how their weapons train on real
people like they want to see what how it
works you know what this is what this
was the article that they were arguing
that case had some people well you see
it in in domestic life all the time you
know some you know it just was so
astounding to me when uh it's too too
common now to even be news but somebody
would be robbing a store and somebody
would be lying on the floor just trying
to hide and the hoodlum comes in it just
fills the person with bullets I mean
can I I want to ask you um uh
going back to the you know you're
talking about the 50s or 60s and 70s
World War II
I'm not uh I'm I'm 37 I'm curious with
everything we're seeing in today with
political conflict as you mentioned with
crime was it at all like this in the 60s
70s and the 50s or anything like that
well I I wrote something recently that
uh what it was like in 1945 because
everybody said the world's going to end
tomorrow and things are very very bad
and I agreed with that I talk about it
all the time but then I just went over
the statistics of World War uh World War
one and World War II millions of people
died you know and it was it was very a
disaster so it's it's continued but the
founders made the point and I'm a strong
believer in it that ultimately the kind
of society we have depends on a
prevailing attitude both intellectually
and spiritually of of a community
because uh you know the non-aggression
in principle fortunately is can be used
by people in a spiritual realm or in a
pragmatic Zone you know just say this
this doesn't this doesn't make any sense
and uh yet uh yeah we we continue to do
it but I think it's the nature of
mankind and I I never I never heard
discussions uh about nihilism of course
that's been discussed in the philosophy
books for a long time but nothing like
it's talked about now and I've sort of
been concentrating on that at that
because if you don't have truth which we
don't have anymore uh then you have
dialists and you're dealing with people
that have no conscience
and when you understand that then you
understand the people who just shoot to
kill and and do all these things and do
all and what that's going to cause chaos
and people are going to die ah that'll
open the doors for True Marxism we have
to get rid of all this garbage you
people of living with so for us to
devise you you know the the perfect
social State we need to get rid of all
these Notions of about uh about freedom
and capitalism and honest money and that
is their their goal and and since
they're nihilist they don't care so do
you think that the reason we're seeing
the spike in crime is that
these people are intentionally releasing
criminals and and you know making not
enforcing laws because they want to
destroy the system well I think that
they've just lost all contact with
reality I think they are Psychopathic in
essence a psychopath has lost uh uh you
know contact with reality and uh and and
that sort of can be a collective thing
the mob psychology I mean we're we're
operating sort of with a mob psychology
that people are joining us uh and they
have all kinds of excuses I I've been
you know as much as I try to think about
this uh you know getting all these
corporations and so many people to go
along with this lockdown you know and
most of them are you know you think they
they they can't be they can't be as far
off as I described but they uh they just
go they go along with it and uh it's
it's sort of scary but I think I think
the person so the uh the the point that
the founders made is uh they said this
constitution isn't worth much if the
people are immoral and have no
principles and they don't believe in
truth how can they believe in honest
money if they don't have any principles
and and they don't have a a unit of
account they don't have a unit of
account for the money they don't have a
unit of account for social matters
perhaps this is why they're saying two
plus two equals five
which was a a big thing they're still
pushing to be honest what is a woman you
said something yeah that's it that's a
good example you said something really
profound about the non-aggression
principle in in regards to spirituality
like I know about non-aggression
principle militarily but the idea that
in a community in a conversation you
could have a non-aggression principle
with another human and that if you live
like that maybe it'll create a society
where then that starts to happen but it
happens all the time I've made
optimistic statements and I have to be
careful because it sounds too optimistic
I say I remember growing up as a kid in
a depression in World War II I was in uh
grade school and high school College
medical school military and I said
there's hardly anybody that I met that I
thought was a real scoundrel
my neighbors had been easy to get along
with and and and and and and and we
happen to be Believers so the people we
associated with in a spiritual way they
were never a threat to us so there were
a lot so my impression if it was my
narrow impression but people most people
would say yeah babe what a boring life
you had you know and and they wouldn't
accept this because life is much
different and you have to you have to
have a good time too you know well the
the old curse may you live in
interesting times yeah so maybe it's
kind of good when your life is boring
you get to focus on your passions you
get to take care of your family it's
good to be forceful in your life but not
necessarily aggro like there's
difference a different in B in like
forcing your personality and beliefs on
someone and being aggressive with it
well this is this is the issue I see
today we have what we would refer to as
the left and the right or whatever words
you want to use to describe you know
wokeness and freedom or whatever one
faction says lie cheat and steal because
the only truth is power or there is no
truth but Power the other side is an
amalgam of different ideologies that all
tend to agree on the rights of the
individual so I think while all of us in
this room May disagree on certain you
know principles or philosophies we
mostly agree with life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and that's where we
differ with those who seek to use
aggression against us or others to
control them and gain power we actually
think people should be free to live
their lives you know but I I think
people uh
the shortcomings comes from I'll use the
word conservative but the conservative
element sometimes wants to tell you
exactly how you should live but if a
conservative who wants to do that
accepts the principle of non-aggression
uh yes he can be critical he might want
to approve it because uh if it happens
to be somebody your family or a friend
and they're they're killing themselves
with drugs and all that you might you
know try to help people but I I I think
that the people uh you know you know
will respond but uh the the problem is
is that that there's this momentum and I
think economics have a lot to do with it
you know because things things uh even
though there's still a lot of wealth in
this country and and people are think
they're a lot richer than they really
are because it's all on debt and uh
that's why bad times are coming because
because it's going to get worse when
they know how poor they really are well
there's a couple questions I have for
you why do you think we're seeing this
explosion of homelessness in so many
major cities and why is it that they are
at the same time I think is it related
don't get me wrong but I'm bringing them
both up they say that it's hard to find
workers but we're also seeing them this
wave of unemployment I'm sorry of
homelessness you'd think those two
things would solve themselves I I think
it's a reflection of stupid policy
welfarism and uh that means that they
know it look what look what happened
when the when the covet broke out and
people wanted to take advantage of it
everybody got checks big checks and they
have so much money that they printed is
sitting around how are we going to spend
all so they feel they feel like they can
trust that but the trouble is is the
payment comes in a different way the
taxes are very high much higher than
they really think the liquidation of
debt the default people keep worrying
about with a government not send me my
check is there going to be a default the
default is Rip roaring and it's going to
get a lot worse that means that if I
owed you a hundred dollars last week and
I can give it to you today uh it's only
worth fifty dollars you've lost fifty
dollars and governments do that they
steal from you and they transfer wealth
and that's that's where the real problem
and people don't understand that because
they say the one statement that I've
heard for so many years is the people
who get into trouble as a result of the
stupid government they say uh the the
only problem I have is I don't have
enough money to pay pay my bills I go to
the grocery store and it's two hundred
dollars and I only have a hundred
dollars so it's always a shortage of
money and the problem is there's too
much money printed out of thin air and
it doesn't have value to it there's no
unit of account so having a unit of
account in Social things in economic
matters I think are very similar this is
how I explain it to people I went on to
Amazon and I was searching for a tablet
put it in my shopping cart and I think
it was like four hundred and seventy
dollars I forgot to buy it
two days later or so I go back on Amazon
and there's a notice it says a price
change for an item in your cart I click
it and it says this item is now six
hundred dollars
this is the easiest way for the average
person to understand how inflation is
happening so rapidly
it was I I could have bought it two days
ago for you know 150 bucks less well
that means if you were if you if you did
a pla if you made a plan and said okay I
make X dollars per hour I have why bills
and the tablet cost Z that means I have
to work this many hours to be able to
buy this tablet at the end of the month
so you work those hours and then by the
time the end of the month comes the
tablet now costs twice as much because
you weren't actually making any money as
you were working your job and saving you
are losing money
see uh free market Austrian econ economy
is completely different than keysianism
casinism believes in the computer you
put in the numbers and they'll tell us
print a hundred dollars here and the
people will do this it's not true it
never works out because one one the
principles of Austrian economics that
has helped me understand it is the uh is
the uh
artificiality of it it's the the pseudo
theory that that you can't you can't
measure things that way because there's
a psychological Factor there and uh it's
it's how badly we want so if if we
doubled the money supply in this room uh
we're not all going to do the same thing
you can't you can't tell what the people
will do what they're measuring be some
might save it some might spend it that's
why that's why this Theory this
subjective theory of value I think
explains it that's why it's a mishmash
that's why you can go you know uh 10 10
years and gold prices doesn't move and
yet they've been predominated like crazy
then all of a sudden we have our our
prices going up but that's all
explainable through Austrian economics I
I did find that really interesting that
the price of gold has been fairly
stagnant I think over the past 10 years
is that artificial is it being
artificial well there's a lot of money
that's the most important price fixing
that they can do because the goal we
eventually will measure value no matter
they will be the unit of account and uh
that's the last thing that they have to
cling to uh to say that uh the dollar
still has value and they've been able to
manipulate boy ever since Roosevelt went
in and took the gold in it was 35 an
hour and all that but they they I think
even today they can manipulate that
price of gold and oh I'm way off I was
way wrong on that sorry but they will
have to uh you know eventually there's
gonna there's gonna be chaos from them
and that's why we would like to try to
avoid it real quick just a correction in
January of 2001 gold was 265 an ounce it
reached a peak around September of 2011
at 1700 it dipped Down August 2015 to
1121 and as of today it is bouncing
around near 2000 and officially crossed
to 2018 so actually
it skyrocketed after the first economic
crisis went down a little bit and then
skyrocketed back up again with the past
economic crisis so yeah gold is gold is
way up okay that thousand dollars was
his 19th uh 2015 or something yes
I watched that as the beginning of the
current bull market in Gold because you
had bull market 35 up to 800 then you
had a thousand up to uh well what the
second one but this is the third one
where it was a thousand dollars now it's
up to two thousand dollars and I think
it's just the beginning if you look at
percentages of what happens at a bull
market in Gold what's the percentage
going from 35 up to 800 even though it
didn't stay there that's that's the
movement that it had 250 percent or
something like that is it it's possible
it's more more than that it's possible
we'll see like a 10x increase in the
cost of gold the value of gold I don't
know what you call it cost or value is
the same is the the word interchangeable
but like could you see gold going up by
one magnitude from 2000 twenty thousand
an ounce yeah I think it'll go to zero I
mean I think it won't be in trading I
mean I think the dollar will go to zero
before that but no yes it will if
they've held it together longer yeah
yeah
I think in your lifetime you'll see gold
at five thousand dollars an ounce if
they can keep it from totally crashing
the economic system I I I agree I'm
looking at this chart right now and it
compares the dollar the Dow Jones the S
P 500 and gold and if in the year 2000
you invested all your money in Gold it
would be worth twice as much as stock in
the Dow Jones or s p 500. did you
compare it to crypto uh if you bought
Bitcoin uh around uh 2009 or whatever it
would be worth twenty thousand percent
so from the beginning from the beginning
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time